مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم في المقابله بدا
السودان موحدا عند استقلاله وانتهى به
المطاف الى سودانين واحد متعثر في الجنوب
واخر متعثر في الشمال اخترت في هذه الحلقه
والحلقه التي تليها ان استعرض سيره الدوله
الحديثه في السودان من زاويه تجربه شخص
لافته وفي غايه الاهميه تجربه الدكتور
منصور خالد واحد من اهم مثقفي وسياسي
السودان الرجل الذي تولى منصب وزير
الخارجيه في بدايات عهد جعفر نوميري
وانتقل بعد ذلك بعد عقد من الزمان الى
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان استعرض مع
الرجل تاريخ الدوله الحديثه والمحطات
الرئيسيه في حياته وفي حياه الدوله
الحديثه
للسودان ولد الدكتور منصور خالد في مدينه
ام درمان بالسودان عام
1931 التحق بكليه الحقوق بجامعه الخرطوم
وحصل على شهاده البكالريوس عام
55 حصل على شهاده الماجستير في القانون من
جامعه بنسلفانيا بالولايات المتحده عام 63
ثم نال شهاده الدكتوراه من جامعه باريس
عام
66 في بدايه مسيرته عمل منصور خالد محاميا
قبل ان ينتقل للعمل بالامم المتحده في
مدينه نيويورك انتقل بعدها الى الجزائر
ليعمل في برنامج الامم المتحده الانمائي
ثم منظمه اليونسكو في باريس بعد انقلاب
العقيد جعفر نميري عام 69 وتوليه السلطه
عين منصور خالد وزيرا للشباب والرياضه وهو
المنصب الذي بقي فيه حتى استقالته في
اغسطس من العام التالي عاد بعدها الى
الامم المتحده ليعمل سفيرا للسودان في
المنظمه الدوليه بعد فشل انقلاب هاشم
العطا في عام 71 طلب النميري من منصور
خالد العوده الى الخرطوم ليتولى وزاره
الخارجيه لعب دورا بارزا في المفاوضات
التي ادت الى اتفاقيه اديس ابابا عام 72
وهي الاتفاقيه التي انهت الحرب الاهليه
الاولى في السودان وتولى بعد ذلك وزاره
التربيه والتعليم قبل تعيينه مساعدا لرئيس
الجمهوريه في اواخر السبعينات استقال
منصور خالد من المكتب السياسي وخرج تماما
من نظام النميري وانتقل بعدها ليعمل في
مركز ودرو ويلسون الدولي العلماء بواشنطن
في اوائل الثمانينات شغل منصور منصب نائب
رئيس اللجنه الدوليه للبيئه والتنميه ثم
اثار الكثير من الجدل عام 84 عقب انضمامه
للحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان ليكون
مستشارا سياسيا لزعيم الحركه الراحل جون
جرنج وقد لعب دورا هاما في اتفاقيه السلام
الشامل عام 2005 التي انهت الحرب الاهليه
الثانيه بين شمال السودان
وجنوبه للدكتور منصور خالد عدد من
المؤلفات باللغتين العربيه والانجليزيه
منها السودان اهوال الحرب وطموحات السلام
الفجر الكاذب نوميري وتحريف الشريعه وكتاب
انفصال جنوب
[موسيقى]
السودان
حياك الله يا دكتور منصور سعداء بوجودك
اهلا شرفتنا في حلقتين نتحدث فيها عن
سيرتك الطويله وانا ارى انها سيره السودان
الدوله الحديثه السودان شكرا اتحدث معك عن
الولاده انت ولدت في ام درمان في ام درمان
نعم ماذا بقي من ذاكره في ذاكرتك من من
مكان ولادتك ونشك الاولى اه امدرمان مدينه
تقليديه و يعني فيها اشياء كثيره بترخ في
ذهن هي الحيا الاسريه ا
ال المشاهد ال
ال في في في في مناطقه السكن في الاسواق
في ك بيئه ريفيه لا بيئه مدينيه مدينيه
بيئه مدينيه اه
و يعني انا
الحقيقه ما عايز اقول متيم بها لكن بحبها
بتحبها اي الان تعيش فيها ام في الخرطوم
بعيش في الخرطوم الخرطوم ايوه لكن اسرتي
مازلت تعيش هناك ما الاسره التي ولدت فيها
دكتور ص اسره
دينيه صوفيه صوفيه و هي
اسرى عبد المجود نعم واسهم واسهام حقيقه
كثير في في نشر العلم في المدينه او في
الحقيقه في القطر لانه كان كثير من كثير
من الطلاب بيجوا الحواريين بيجوا من مناطق
مختلفه س ولحص الحظ يعني نحنا نستعد الان
لاعاده
افتتاح المسجد
والخلوه تصوف انا ش شخصيا اي لا همت
بالصوفيه كتبت الثلاثيه الجديه ايوه انا
الحقيقه لم ا تصوف لكن كنت دائما معجب
بالصوفيه لانهم في تقديري ناس صادقين اكثر
مما يسمون ب من يسمون بال بالعلماء
المتصوفه المتصوفه بد هذا التيار سائد في
السودان كثيره هذ المدرسه الصوفيه اي
مدرسه الصوفيه كثيره من اثر بك والدك جدك
من رتك جدي جدي
وعمي اسروا عليه كثير جدا حتى في
كتابي الثلاثيه المجديه في كثير عنهم كتبت
عن عنهما عن الجد والعم عن الجد وال انت
طبعا اسرتك واحده من الام ومن الاب بالضبط
هي نفس الاسره نف درست في ام درمان حتى
متى يا دكتور درست في ام درمان طوال نحن
نقول درمان هي
الدرمه المرحله
الابتدائيه لغايه المرحله الابتدائيه
الاوليه الابتدائيه ومن بعد على وادي
سيدنا لدراسه الانبيه واحده من المناطق
المحيطه بامدرمان ومنها الى بنسلفانيا لا
الحقوق درستها في الخرطوم درستها في
الخرطوم ا وثم ذهبت الى الجو مختلف بين
الخرطوم وامدرمان ولا لا طبيعه واحده
طبيعه واحده طبيعه واحده ما الذي جرى
حينما انتقلت لولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اول مره في اي سنه تذكر دتور ا انتقلت
للمره الاولى المره الاولى دي كانت في
فتره في الواقع يعني في فتره خصبه دي
الفتره اللي اللي كان فيها كندي في الحكم
وكان فيها احداث
واشنطن الخطبه المشهوره ل
ل
انا لي
شكوى نذكر
القص المشهور القص الامريكي القص اي لوثر
مارتن لوثر مارتن لوثر كو كانت فتره فاصله
وتعلمت منها اشياء كثيره ماذا
تعلمت تعلمت بانه ما في شيء اقبح من الميز
العنصري لانه لا منطقه فيه انك تحكم على
الشخص على اساس لونه اساس عرقه
ده بيدل على غباء يعني
وتلمت ايضا انه النضال ضد هذا النوع من
الميز ما بيجي من السوق بس او السمبر بس
وانما في ناس
كثيرين من البيض على راسهم كندي مثلا يقال
دكتور منصور هامه بالغرب وتشكلت لديه
علاقات قويه
و بالمؤسسات الدوليه هل ثمت علاقه خاصه
تربطك بالثقافه الغربيه خاصه في ظل الصراع
الغربي
الراسمالي الشيوعي شوف
يعني هام بالغرب نعم نهمت بالغربي كثيرا
ولانه اذا نظرت اليه من ناحيه المكسب
العلمي اذا نظرت منحه المكسب الاجتماعي
اذا نظرت ال من ناح القيم اللي بزود بها
حريات حقوق الانسان حريات حقوق
الانسان دي كلها لها اثر كبير لاثر ك لكن
الناس في السودان كانوا كارهين لهذا
التوجه والله هم بيقولوا كارهين كذابين
لانه هم يعني يكرهون الارض لفظيا لكن اللي
بيمرض منهم لابد يمشي للانض يتعالج اللي
عايز يتاجر لابد يمشي للندن وباريس وكذا
ففي في نفاق في في خضع خداع للنفس الليفا
كيف تصف السودان
الستينات السودان الستينات جميل كان وفتره
عز شبابك في الثلاثينات بالضبط بالضبط
وبعدين الجيل اللي كان موجود رامي نقدي
لهم السياسي لكن بفتكر انه
عندهم يعني صدق مع النفس
و في شرف هذا كان في قيم في قيم في قيم
اجت جماعيه وقدم
اخلاقيه افتكر انه
يعني الواحد بينظر له بحنين رغم اني بنتقد
انتقاد مر السياسه لانه حنين للثقافه
والقيم بالضبط التزام كانت الامور غالبا
افضل تعتقد السودان اليوم سياسيا كدوله
اسوا بكثير مما كان يجب ان يكون عليه اسوا
بكثير نعم واسوا لا هو اسوا
بكثير سقوط القيم دي انا بسمي المرحله دي
هي
مرحله قبول اي شيء القيم ما ما في معايير
انتهت المعايير وكل شخص بيخطي وكل شخص
بيتوقع انه الاخر يقبل خطاه دكتور عندنا
قضايا كثيره نناقشها على طاوله الحوار نعم
لكن قبل ذلك يقول زهير ابن ابي سلمى سئمت
تكاليف الحياه ومن يعش 80 حول لا اب لك يا
لا اب لك لا ابك هل سئمت تكاليف الحياه
وانت عملت
وانتجت امورا كثيره يعني سنستعرضها والله
كيف تصل لنا حالك اليوم شوف يعني طالما
انت اعدت ب
الى الادب الجاهل انا اعود بك الى الحارس
عندما قال ان الثمانين
وبلغها قد احوجت سمعي اللا ترجم
وانا انا انا محتاج الى ترجمان لانني اكاد
اعيش في مجتمع ا لا افهم ولا
يفهمني تشعر بالغربه الاغتراب بينك وبين
المحيط فيه والله بشعر بالغربه لانه يعني
انا بجد في شيء عجيب
يعني عند البشر الان انهم يحتملوا اي شيء
اي شيء يسرق شخص قدامك يقتل شخص قدامك بد
يقبلون كل شيء شي كل شيء اصبح مقبول
بالضبط بالضبط اد سميت انا فقه الاستباحه
تعكف على كتابه مذكراتك دكتور نعم ترصد
فيها كل شيء كل شيء وبصدق يعني
انا انا عايز اروح حقائق طبعا سنستمع في
الحلقتين الى جزء كبير منها ولكن هل كتابه
المذكرات و خاصه انه في احيانا تشخيص
لاخطاء تشخيص لربما جرائم قام بها اشخاص
يبدو كانه صعب في ثقافتنا العربيه الى حد
ما هل واجهت الصعوبه وانت تكتبها بسعى
دائما لانه اقول الحقيقه دائما يعني بيعصر
عليك لما تكون متكلم عن
الصديق ان تقول كل الحقيقه لكن يعني
الحقائق التي يجب ان يعرفها الشخص يعرفها
القارئ لا اتردد في وصفه ارحب بك مجددا
وننتقل الى طاوله الحوار ونستعرض هذه
السيره الطويله والغنيه والثريه حقيقه
جزلا واكرر طبعا شكري على قبولك دعوتك
شكرا جزيلا شكرا
شكرا اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام ارحب
بكم وارحب بضيفي المقابله في حلقتين دكتور
منصور خالد وكما ذكرت في بدايه البرنامج
ثمت شخصيات ثمت سير شخصيه وذاتيه تؤرخ ل
سيره الدول حقيقه اليوم الدكتور منصور
خالد حينما اتحدث معك ارحب بك من جديد
وحينما اتحدث معك واستعرض هذه المحطات
الرئيسيه في حياتك كانني استعرض تاريخ
الدوله الحديثه في السودان تحدثنا في
الجزء الاول عن ولادتك واسرتك ودراستك
ونشات
الاولى عملت في 56 سكرتير رئيس الحكومه مع
استقلال السودان
ا في الواقع يعني هذا امر شايع ا
ا نعم عملت
مع رئيس وزراء السودان وقتها عبد الله
خليل ا لكن كنت سكرتيرا صحفيا له لم اكن
في وظيفه حكوميه حكوميه بدليل انني كنت
محاميا ايضا لا يمكن ان تجمع بين المحاماه
ووظيفه الحكوميه لكن كنت
ا سكرتير الصحفيه له ورافقته في الكثير من
رحلاته وقمت بعض الواجبات ببعض الواجب
اللي كلفني بها ما ماذا تذكر عن الرجل نعم
ماذا تذكر عن الرجل وعن تلك الفتره نشاه
السودان بعد
الاستقلال الرجل في تقديري هو واحد من
اربعه او خمسه سودانيين من جيله ا اظن
انهم تركوا ميسم هام في تاريخ البلد
والذي اعنيه بهذا الميسم الهام هو ميسم
هام في احترام القانون ا دكتور يبدو انه
هذه
السمه هذه الرصانه يبدو انها سمه الموظفين
كبار الموظفين في الدوله العربيه في تلك
الفتره في الاربعينات والخمسينات قبل ان
يفسد الناس وان يفسد الموظفون وقبل هذا
صحيح هذا صحيح لانه في انهيار الدوله حدث
عندما
ا تحولت الدوله بدلا من جهاز يحكم قانون
ويحقق اهداف معينه اصبحت جهاز ايديولوجي
تسيطر على ايديولوجيه معينه
والايديولوجيات
دائما تحمل صاحبه لاحتقان اي شيء يجب في
طريقه بما في ذلك القانون حتى القانون
القانون
الالهي الذين يقودون مثلا عملا سياسيا
الان ويزعمون ان
انهم
يتقفل لكنهم يفعلون كل شيء ينهى عنه
القران اذا النقطه التي اثرها صحيح عملت
في ثلاث مسارات نعم محاماه كمسار ووظيفه
الدوله التي تقطعت ولكن لاحقا يعني عملتها
بشكل رسمي مع الدوله وكذلك العمل الاممي
مع مع الامم المتحده واجهزتها المختلفه ما
الذي استحوذ عليك بشكل اكبر من الاخر
في كل مجال تعلمت شيء عملي مثلا في
المحاماه كان عندك مكتب محام كان عندي
مكتب
محاماه في البدء مع محامي كبير مشهور هو
ايميل
قرنفلي وثم عملت المكتب
الخاص تعلمت في الواقع الكثير من عن من
المحاماه قبل ان التحق بهذه المهمه في
الفتره التدريبيه
مع رجل يعني له اثر كبير على
حياتي المهنيه
وال غير المهنيه هو الاستاذ احمد متولي
العتباني كان النائب العام اول نائب عام
بعد استقلال السودان
وعملت معه مع صديق رحمه الله هو عبد
الرحمن يوسف في مرحله اظنها اخطر مرحله
في تاريخ السوداني و مرحله الانتقال من
الفتره الانتقاليه
للاستقلال لماذا كانت اخطر مرحله نعم
لماذا كانت اخطر مرحله اخطر مرحله لانه
ا السودانيين يعني ياتوا
ببدع
اتفاقيه الاتفاقيه المصريه البريطانيه نصت
على كيف يتحقق الاستقلال عبر استفتاء يتم
بين ا يتم بيننا السودانيين للاختيار بين
وحده السودان مع مصر او
الاستقلال
وفجاه دعاه الوحده مع مصر هم الذين
اقترحوا ان يعلن الاستقلال من داخل
البرلمان هذا يعني تعديل في الدستور كانت
هذه بدعه ب بظ انها بدوريه قانونيه هي هي
بدعه ويعني حتى من الناحيه السياسيه تجعل
المر يشك كثير في صدق القوى السياسيه التي
كانت تدعو للوحده لا يمكن ان تكون حياتك
السياسيه كلها قائمه على الوحده ثم تقرر
بانه الوحده لا
ت يقرر فيها الشعب السوداني وانما يحصل
قرار من البرلمان على اي حال ديم الاشياء
اللي تعلمتها وهذا هذا يعني هذا راجع لوصف
كانها كانت مرحله دقيقه وخطره في تاريخ
السودان في تلك الفتره عملك الاممي اثر
بشكل كبير وبنى شخصيه منصور خالد واسمه
ومكانته داخل السودان وخارج السودان متى
التحقت اول مره بجهاز الامم المتحده
التحقت بالامم المتحده حقيقه في
مرحلتين المرحله الاولى بعد نيلي لشهاده
الماجستير من جامعه بنسلفانيا
ا طلب مني في الواقع استاذي وقال لي انا
راغب طلب مني في الامم المتحده ان ارشح
شخص فهل لديك رغبه فرشح ني
فعلا والتحقت
بال اداره القانونيه وكنت نورك في نيويورك
وكنت ثاني افريقي كنا اثنين بس ففارق
يعملون في تلك الاداره وفي الواقع هذا
استمر الى متى يا
دكتور ثلاث سنوات ثم مريت في الامم
المتحده انتقلت الى الجزائر
كمساعد
لمندوب بررنامج التنميه ا في الجزائر ودي
فتره طبعا اثرت علي هذه مرحله مهمه وانا
اعرف انها اثرت فيك وغيرت من من فكرك نعم
عندي نقطتين اولا ما الذي جرى معك في
الجزائر على صعيد التشكل الفكري ثم ساعود
للامم المتحده وعلاقاتك مع الغرب في
الجزائر اولا الجزائر يعني اي كانت الفتره
دي فتره
ا
فتره
يعني خلاف فكري شديد في داخل الح اي اي
عام لو سمحت دكتور 56 56 او 5 65 655 بعد
الاستقلال بعد الاستقلال ا صراع بين ب
مدين وبن بلا ا وكان لابد الصرده ان يحسم
وحسم ب اسلاد استيلاء ابو مدن عن الحكم او
الشق العسكري وهم ما يحبوا يسموه الشق
العسكري وفعلا انا ما بسموه الشق العسكري
لكن الشق الجيش الشعبي ا
ا في الفتره دي كانت الجزائر
بوتقه لكثير من التحركات التقيت في المره
الاولى يمكن في حياتي التقي بزعماء
فريق كان في وقتها في مناضلين مناضلين
المناضلين الفارقه يعني التقيت بهم
هناك المره الاولى بشوف في بلد بما في ذلك
بلد السودان القضايا الافريقيه
بتشغل ال بال المفكرين والحكام كثير عندما
تقول ل اقول هذا الكلام
لاخواني بيميز منه بيقولوا لا نحن اعترفنا
بالبلد الفلانيه و باعتراف بالبلد الا لكن
دي ما القضيه القضيه الاهتمام
بقضايا هذه الشعوب بنضالات هذه الشعوب
بالتعلم من تجاربها بتعليم الشيء عن تجربه
السودان كانت الجزائر مركز النشاط العربي
والنشاط
الافريقي بالضبط كانت مركز الجزائ النشاط
العربي والنشاط الافريقي كيف تاثرت تقول
انك تاثرت كثيرا من هذه التجربه ما الذي
جرى على الصعيد الفكري
اولا انا استطيع ان اقول انني
كنت لا اريد ان اقول انني كنت
يمينيا ولكنني لم اكن من هوه اليسار لا بس
يقولون عنك انك انت كنت غربي امريكي الهوا
من البدايه لا يعني هي امريكا الهوا
ماذا يعني امريك امريكي الهوا ما الذي انا
احب امريكا جدا اولا انا ترى ناقل الكفر
ليس
بكافر انا احب امريكا جدا تعلمت فيها
الكثير وما زال في اشياء تربطني
بها اجتماعيا وثقافيا وسياسيا وسياسيا
طبعا طيب سناتي للتفاصيل انا بس اطلب منك
حتى بس تكون الامور واضحه قبل الجزائر كنت
يمينيا حسب التصنيف يصنفون الاخرون صنفك
ماذا تصنف نفسك انت
ا
لل هل القول انك لم تكن يساريا كان توصيفا
كافيا لك في تلك المرحله انا
يعني بدون
غرور كثيرا
ماستخدم
تعليق الرئيس دجول عندما سئل هل انت يميني
او ام يساري رد كان انا
فوقهما جوسوي اديسو انا اعلى منهم وانت
هذا شعورك في تلك ال هذا شعوري وما زال
هذا شعوري لسبب واحد هو انه اليمين انداح
في اليسار واليسار انداح في اليمين لكن
لما رحت الجزائر ما صرت اعلى منهم ايش ايش
اللي
حصل تعلمت تجربه كما قلت اللي رمت ب الى
ما يمكن ان تسميه يسار ن الى اي
درجه مثلا انا المامي بالقضايا
الافريقيه كان قليل في ذلك الوقت لانه
المجتمع الذي عشت فيه لم يهتم بها بل اقول
في شيء خطير جدا السودانيين لا يتحدثون
عنه نحن البلد الوحيد في افريقيا الذي لا
يريد ان يحترف حتى الان
بافريقيا مش بافريقيا بان تجاره الرقيق
كانت تمارس فيه ولدت
اجيال كثيره جدا لا يعترف ب ا انتماء
للبلد لانهم ليسوا بعرب
وكانما الذي يقول هذا الكلام لا ينظر الى
وجهه في المرى هل تقول انه الهوى العربي
للسودانيين كان هو الاكثر تاثيرا والاكثر
بالذات للشمال السودانيين في الشمال كان
هو الاكثر تاثيرا على على السياسه
والثقافه والفكر بالطبع بالطبع دائما رحت
ل للاتجاه الاخر لا انا ما رحت لتجاه
الاخر في الواقع الاتجاه الاخر في رايه هو
اتجاه سوداني السودان بوتقه نشات فيها
مجموعات عرقيه مختلفه
وتشكلت من نتيجه الاختلاط الذي حدث يجب ان
يعترف بهذا طيب دكتور حتى بس لان هذه مهمه
اللي حصل في الجزائر انت قلت انه كنت فوق
الافكار فوق
التيارات بس انت على
هديه وثم ذهبت للجزائر الانشغال بالقضايا
الافريقيه جعلك اقرب لليسار قليلا ماذا
بعد ما الذي جعلك يساريا او ما القضيه
التي دفعتك الى ان تشعر بانك اصبحت اكثر
يسارا الاهتمام اولا
بال بالهويه انه هذه الهويه هويه مشتركه
عربيه افريقيه
ا بالنسبه للجزائر امازيغيه الاعتراف في
كل المكونات للمجتمع خاصه لمجتمعات تو
خرجت من الاستعمار بالضبط تبحث عن هويتها
عن صورتها عن كذا بالضبط بالضبط واقتصاديا
تحولت الى يساري
ولا فكريا طبعا من الناحيه الفكريه بديت
التفكير في ما يسمى بالاشتراك اشتراكي
كثيره طبعا استمريت طويلا في هذه في هذا
الجو ولا ارتديت عنه استمريت في هذه
الجنون استمريت هذه الجنون ا حتى تسميه
جنون دكتور نعم الذي حدث
للاتجاهات
الماركسيه في
نهايه القرن الماضي في الاتحاد السوفيتي
يجب ان يكون دليلا على على صحه وصف وعندما
نحدث على الجنون الجنون بالمناسبه انا لا
اتحدث عن الرؤى الفلسفيه ماركسيه
مساء هذه الرؤى الفلسفيه هي جزء من
التطور الفكري البشري في العالم البري وفي
الواقع اعد دور يعني تحدث عن عن السياسات
وال السياسات والترجمه لهذه الافكار من
الاجيال ال اثرت فيك تجربه الجزائر كثيرا
كثير بعود لنقطه الغرب لاني رح تستمر معي
في الحلقتين وبعدين نعود الى الى الى
السودان وعمل الملك اللافت فيما بعد مع
جعفر
نميري ليش تنزعج لما يقولون والله الدكتور
منصور خالد هو غربي الهواى انت مرتبط
بالمؤسسات الدوليه اللي الغرب يؤثر فيها
او تميل للغرب تميل لرؤيه الغرب من فتره
مبكر حتى انه في اتهامات لك كانت يعني
تجاوزت في في محاوله ادانته الى اخره فهل
تشعر بالانزعاج من هذا الامر او انا لا
اشعر بانزعاج مطلقا لانه
انا درست في فرنسا درست في امريكا عملت في
البلدين
وشفت عالم ما ما اتيح لي ان اشوفه والشيء
المحسن جدا انه اكثر الناس حديثا
عن هوايا للغرب هم اليسارين انا لم اسمع
بيسار مثلا قرر يعيش في موسكو لم اسمع
بزري قرر يعيش في بيكين لندن بروح لندن
ولا باريس ولا نوور بالضبط بالضبط تعتقد
ان هذا المعسكر الغربي هو الاكثر اغراء في
العالم تاثيرا بدون شك بدون شك للتقدم
اللي احرزه التقدم الاجتماعي التقدم
الثقافي ا في النسبه بالنسبه للحياه
الحريات قطعا بس دكتور في في الخمسينات
نهايه الخمسينات والستينات كان المد
اليساري هو الاقوى الاكثر تاثيرا الاكثر
شعبيه في المنطقه العربيه وكان كان من
يتجه باتجاه اخر كانه يعني دائما في في
وضع الشبهه او يودان صح الحركات القوميه
عبد الناصر مد الناصري الاتجاه اليساري
الحركات البعثيه كانت هي الاكثر تاثيرا ما
دخلت في قلبك ما اخترقت هذا الوجدان ما ما
وهذا الشعب لم تستطيع ان تاسره كل هذه
التيارات العربيه لا تاثرت ب انت قلت اني
تاثرت في الجزائر
مثلا وكان لي
صداقات كثيره في في مصر يعني بين المفكرين
كلهم يساريين لطفي
خولي
احمد بهاء الدين احمد بهاء
الدين قد تستغرب انه من اصدقائي الحميمين
كانوا من السوريين ابراهيم ماخس ف دول
كلهم يعني الاسلاميين ما كان لهم حضور
رموز الاسلاميه الفكريه في تلك الفتره
انقذني الله منهم انقذك الله منهم ايوه
انا انا عندنا محور كامل على الاسلام ايوه
انا في مره من المرات انا معجب
بالعقاد
و
باعجابي العقاد قادني الى الاعجاب بالسيد
قطب واعجبت به لسببين سبب الاول انه هو
كان
يعني بيقدر الشخصيه المصريه اللي هي
الشخصيه الفرعونيه
وقد كتب مقاله او رساله في الواقع لعلي
ماهر باشا كان وزير التعليم بيطلب منه ان
يجعل من روايه نجيب محفوظ راديو بيس جزء
من المنج
الدراسي ايضا قرات له
ل سيد قطب نعم تتحدث عن سيد قطب سيد قطب
قرات له ايضا نقدا لعبد الرحمن
الرافعي ساء فيه العقاد اعجابي به كان
لاعجابه بالعقاد لاحترامه للشخصيه كملت
اعجابك بسيد قطب في افكاره الاخرى ولا لا
زرته انا زرت سيد قطب زرت سيد قطب في اي
سنه تذكر دكتور وانا في في جاي من الجزائر
كان
فزرته والذي قادني اليه
صديق سوداني كان طالب هناك اصبح رئيسا
لحزب لاخوان المسلمين وانا لا اعرف مطلقا
لم اكن اعرف شيء عن هويته لكن ذكرت له
مره كان رفيقا لابن
عمي كطلبه هو كان طالب في الواقع فقال لي
ارتب لك زياره القوه قا بالسيد قطب رحت ل
سيد
قطب وكان الحديث كله عن الجانب الادبي
لكن بعد قليل ظهر علينا الرجل
بانه يريد ان يكون استاذا
للعالم ويريد ان يكون استاذا للعالم
بالعوده به الى
الخلف فاوقفت اوقفت اعجابك اي كيف كان
تاثير القاهره عليكم في تلك الفتره دكتور
انتم كمثقفين سودانيين العلاقه مركبه
وعميقه بين القاهره والخرطوم بين مصر
والسودان في علاقه طبعا يعني ناس بيسموها
ازليه في السودان انا لما صحت وزير
خارجيه قررت ان اخرج من القوالب دي ان
يكون العلاقه قلت نحن نسمي
علاقتنا
بمصر علاقه ذات
خصوصيه ده التعبير اللي ظلت استعمله لما
كنت وزير خارجيه وهي خصوصيه اقتضتها ظروف
تاريخيه اقتضتها ظروف ايكولوجيه اقتضتها
مصالح هل تعتقد انها علاقه عادله للطرفين
هي العدل بيجي من ممارسه الطرفين
يعني انت ما تستطيع ان تقول الجغرافيا هي
سبب في عدم عدل القراءه للعلاقه وانما
الطريقه التي يتعامل معها الط ال الاول او
اي طرف مع الطرف الاخر هي التي تحكم به هل
هناك عقده مصريه لدى
السودانيين قد يكون هنالك عقده عننا بعض
المصريين
والسودانيين وذا كان يعني واضح في خاصه في
مقالات بعض الصحفيين اللي يعتبروا انه مصر
هي منفذ السودان
للحضاره وده طبعا راي يعني سايد عند
كثيرين خاصه اللي ما ملمين
بانه في كل بلد في شرق وغرب وفي شمال
وجنوب يعني السودانيون يعرفون المصر تماما
ام لكن الملاحظه انه المصريين لا يعرفون
السودان جيدا صحيح هذه ملاحظه يعني دقيقه
حتى في تلك الفتره كانت لافته يعني في
الخمسينات والستينات كانت الثقافه البصريه
هي السائده وهي الاعلى طبعا كانت ايضا كان
هناك نقص في المعرفه في معرفه السودانيين
كما طبعا كان في نقص كبير يعني الذين
يعرفون مصر في السودان هم اللي كانوا
براوا الرساله ويقرا الهلال وبيقرا وبيشوف
الافلام المصريه لكن المواطن العادي
لا ما كانش بيع
مصر
وبظرها البلد اللي تابعنا نتحدث الان ايضا
ثمه خلافات يعني وطبعا ان شاء الله الكل
يتجاوزها كنت تكتب في الصحا في نهايه
الستينات نعم كنت من المؤثرين من الكتاب
البارزين اين كنت تكتب
ا كنت بكتب في
الايام اغلب ما كتبت كتبته في الايام لكن
كتبت مقالات نشرت في الراي
العام
في مجله اس اسمها
الناس في جريده الامه في عمل كتاب عنها
حوارات الصفوه نعم اول كتاب اول كتاب كان
مجموعه مقالات مجموعه مقالات ودي المقالات
اللي كانت نشرت في الرام قبل انقلاب مايو
69 انقلاب النميري ام كتبت ايضا مجموعه
مقالات تستشعر ان ثمه ضيق في البلد وثمه
تغيير قادم ما الذي يعني دعاك في تلك
الفتره ل التنبؤ بهذا الامر
ا في الواقع نحنا في السودان عندنا اعجاب
فائق ب بانفسنا ا بن تخيل اشياء كثيره ن
نن اعرب العرب نحن اشجع
الشعوب الاشياء ترسبت في عقول الناس
وخلتهم ما يمارسوا نقد ذاتي في كثير من
احيان
يعني الاخطاء اللي وقعت فيها النظام
السوداني هو عدم ادراك الذي يقود السودان
لمحدود امكانياته
لدينا بدون شك مقومات كثيره لكن المقومات
الكثيره دي لا تعطيك الحق في ان تظن انك
انت اعظم من من الاخر خاصه اذا ليس هنالك
ما يبر وده موجود في اغانينا يعني الاغاني
الشعبيه
السودانيه لما تستمع اليها تسهل انه نحن
اعظم شعب في اعتداد كبير ط هي صفه عربيه
يعني معظم الشعوب لكن
يعني هو يعني لانه احنا نشوف العكس يعني
احنا نشوف السودانيين يعني فيهم قدر عالي
من التواضع والبساطه وال صحيح يعني هذا
اللي نشوفه من برا بس اقرا الشعر العربي
يمكن ل نقرا الشعر تطلع اشياء ما ندري ما
خبرونا السودانيين بالشعر ننا نحن ولا
البلد اولاد بلدي معناها انه نحن ال
الانقياء بس انتم هنا هذا الحديث موجه
لسودانيين اخرين لا ده موجه للسوداني نحن
وبلد نقعد نقيف على
كيفنا يعني بتدي نفسك الحق في انك تعمل
انت اللي عاوزه ما الذي جعلك تتنبا بتغيير
سياسي نحيه السينات السياسات اللي كانت
اللي دفعتني للكلام عن عن
ال النخبه السودانيه
وفساده منذ البدء
يعني بعض الاشياء اللي تمت وتعامل معها
المواطن او المواطن المستنير يعني كانها
شيء طبيعي حل الحزب الشيوعي
مثلا
انتخاب يعني
اقدام حزب سياسي منتخب بيقول انه هو حزب
ديمقراطي بطرد نواب انتخبوا نفس الشعب ده
لا يمكن ان يكون الا نذير بكارثه اللي هي
جت في مايو اللي هي جت في مايو ايش كان
شعورك لما حدث هذا الانقلاب
شعرت انه منقذ للسودان شعرت
انه خصك انت بعد سنه انضميت له اقل من سنه
سته اشهر اشهر اشهر وزير الثقافه والشباب
وزيره
الشباب الرياضه والشباب ومدحوا عملك في
تلك الفتره قرات يعني مديح عن الفتره التي
عملت فيها وزيرا وانه كان حتى استثمار
للشباب في في البناء وفي اشياء كثيره جدا
طيب لما حدث انقلاب شعرت انه منقذ لما
تضيف
شيئين يعني احساسي بانه الذي حدث بالنسبه
ل تفضل النواب شيوعيين انا ما شيوعي لكن
كنت بتكلم عن مبدا نواب منتخبين اي الشيء
الثاني
انه نظرتين لفكره الحزب الواحد اللي كنت
تبلغت وان في الجزائر تفر تظافر العاملين
دي شارت انه الحزب الواحد هو الحل الامثل
البلدان في تلك المرحله والنميري هو الذي
بالضبط س يعني يؤدي مهمه القاده السودان
ؤدي كيف صرت وزير دكتور نعم كيف اصبحت
وزير في الحكومه قد تستغرب انا الذي دعاني
لانضمام الحكومه هو نميري شخص و محجوب
عثمان كان وزير الاعلام وهو شيوعي صديق
لي هو رشحك عند نميري هو رشح عن نميري
وعندما حضرت يعني في الاول عشان
تتشاور نمير اقتر علي ان اعمل معه
كمستشار لمجلس الثوره مجلس الرئاسي اي
مجلس الرئاسه محجوب ارادني ان اكون وكيلا
ل
وزارتي وكان ردي على
كليهما بالنسبه لمحجوب ا انا لا اريد ان
ادخلك في صراع مع حزب
لان حزبك عنده مرشح محجوب صديقي جدا وانا
زلت
صداقتنا نرحل
واحترف له دائما بانه من انبل الناس اللي
انا عملت معه بالنسبه للميري قلت له انا
يعني لو فعلت ده بتكون اخلت نفسك في مشكله
قلاي اي مشكله قلت له انت مستشارك الان
للشؤون الخارجيه مستشارك ل
الامور السياسيه هو با بكر عوض الله
نايبك اذا قابلت انك تنشئ مجلس مستشارين
انت
بتغرق مشكله حويك حيكون في نزاع حيكون في
ق اختلاف وجهات نظر وانا ما عازك تدخل
نفسك في هذا المجال ولا تدخلني انا ايضا
في هذا الصراع فانت اقترحت الوزاره الشباب
انا ما اقترحت الوزاره اقترحها بكر ض الله
عليه فقالوا حل ثالث انه انت تكون وزير
لشباب والرياضه اي اي يعني هو الواقع
الاقتراح جا من بابيك عض الله ووافق علي
نميري عملت سنه في الوزاره نعم كيف تصف
دكتور منصور جعفر النميري في تلك الفتره
في اوائل سنين حكمه السنه الاولى 70 شوف
جعفر ال نميري
شخصيه
معقده معقده اي شخص بيعمل انقلاب لابد ان
يكون شخصيه
معقده لانه بجابه ظروف كثيره جدا وبعضها
او اغلبه ما معد مهنيا
ل
ل الاقدام عليها و ظهر طبعا في طوال المده
اللي عمل فيها او عملنا فيها سويا يعني
كان نميري افضل بكثير من نهايات سنين حكمه
بدون في البدايه كان في البدايه كان ا كان
صاحب مشروع عنده رؤيه بتقدير في ذلك الوقت
لم يكن وك كان عنده
رؤيه شاب وطني حاول يعني ينقذ بلده لكن في
نفس الوقت كان متاثر بمن حوله من حوله في
الخارج عبد
الناصر الناصر طبعا كان نموذج كل كل
الحكام العرب الحكام العرب في الداخل لانه
الناس اللي كانوا حوالينه ما كانوا كلهم
على
سويه نميري تولى ايضا مع مجيء القذافي ومع
رحيل عبد الناصر يعني لم كانت 7 رح عبد
الناصر بالضبط كيف كيف كانت علاقته بعبد
الناصر تحديدا في تلك الفتره كيف ماذا
تعرف عنها
اعجاب وما تكون في يعني في نظره اعجاب
الشخص خلاص
سليه يعني انا انا ايضا كنت معجب عبد
الناصر التقيت ب اكثر من مره لكن الان
وانا براجع في التاريخ اقول انه اكبر خطا
انا عملته في التقييم
هو قولي في انه احمد لطفي السيد كان خائنا
احمد لطفي السيد عند طلب منه نجيب بان
يكون رئيس لمجلس
بعد حل مجلس الوصايه مجلس
الدوله تعليقه كان الحكم وا امانه من
الشعب للحاكم انتم لستم الشعب انتم لا انا
ولا انتم
الشعب اذا كان النوع ده من التفكير موجود
وده تفكير رفضوه كل الناس اللي اسمه
انفسهم ادوات التغيير في المستقبل دكتور
انا وصلت الى نهايه الحلقه الاولى ومعك
وصلنا الى بدايه حقبه هامه في تاريخ
السودان تولي جعفر النميري الحكم
والانقلاب طبعا في مايو 69 انقلاب مايو
وما يسمى يعني نظام مايو في السودان وعملك
الذي استمر مع نوميري حتى 78 طبعا توليت
وزاره الخارجيه ثم عملك ايضا في الامم
المتحده
و القضيه الاكبر التي دت بالسودان الى ان
يصبح سودانين لاحقا وموقفك اللافت المنحاز
بشكل كبير الحركه الشعبيه وعملك مع ثمه
قضايا اخرى ايضا اود ان اتناولها معك لكن
مع بدايه الحلقه القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك
وعلى وقتك الذي تمنحنا اياه شكر موصول لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام وصلنا واياكم الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه مع السياسي
والمفكر الدكتور منصور خالد والذي كما
ذكرت حقيقه في بدايه الحلقه انه بتاريخه
الشخصي تستطيع ان تلقي نظره واسعه على
تاريخ السودان الحديث تاريخ الدوله الحديث
في السودان ما بعد الاستقلال وحتى
الانقسام الذي ادى الى فصل البلدين شمال
السودان عن جنوبه شكرا لكم على طيب
المتابعه القاكم الاسبوع المقبل دمتم بخير
في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه